the iPhone 15 is getting even better and
I think many of you guys will not be
able to resist upgrading I know I won't
be able to and in this video I'll
explain what our latest updates are how
plausible that this will come true why
Apple would want to do this and how they
can pull it off now this info comes from
the leaker shrimp Apple Pro which has a
funny name but he has a great track
record for example he was the first one
to show off and give us the design with
the Dual hole punches that ended up
being the dynamic Island which has been
awesome and with that he was the one
that gave us the league CAD images
showing the exact measurements and the
exact design of the iPhone 14 pro and
pro Max he was spot on on that and even
with the iPhone 13 he had great leaks
that turned out to be true now we have
two more pieces of information both that
make me very excited the first first one
is that the iPhone 15 Promax will use a
titanium frame now I am personally
stoked about this for a couple of
reasons first off we've already had
leaks of the iPhone 14 getting a
titanium frame but obviously that did
not happen it's stuck with Aluminum and
Stainless Steel but as we know with the
Apple watch that was leaked to be square
that did end up coming true or partially
true but the leaks were just ahead of
its time because Apple develops products
years in advance so just like the series
7 didn't get that square design the
iPhone 14 didn't get titanium but now
the 15 looks like it definitely could
just like we got the ultra a year later
which has both titanium and a more
Square boxy design now I'm excited for a
couple of reasons first off I have the
ultra so that'd be really cool to be
able to match it and we'll talk about
the possibility of color dollars in just
a bit but second stainless steel is very
heavy and this phone is already 240
grams it's close to the weight of the
fold which is much larger and titanium
is 45
lighter than stainless steel while being
just as durable or even more durable
with the Apple watch Ultra we've seen
people test it out push it through rocks
and try to break it and it is extremely
durable and mine I've hit it against
walls and desks and metal objects and it
still looks like new now there's also a
second part to this leak but looking
through the comments a lot of people are
excited to have titanium to bring the
weight down and of course to make it
more durable now while the titanium
iPhones will be crazy durable with your
current iPhones you need to be much more
careful to keep them safe and Rhino
Shield this video sponsor makes it
personal and easy with their
customizable cases and easy to apply 3D
impact screen protectors for 360 Degree
coverage with the option for privacy or
matte finish there are solid suitcases
are slim while giving you maximum
protection and they have a wide variety
of colors the modern X modular case is
unique because you can switch from an
open back bumper case with a raised Edge
for protection or add a swappable back
plate anytime with thousands of designs
including really cool collaborations and
their magsafe magnets are twice the
strength of apples you also get a
lifetime replacement warranty for the
cases which are available for all
iPhones and many Androids they also have
other accessories like their grip and
Rhino Shield is doing a huge Black
Friday sale with up to 60 off-site wide
as well as an additional 10 off to our
viewers using the code Max Tech so check
out the crazy sale using the link in the
description now I want to mention some
issues with using titanium along with
how Apple will fix that but first I want
to give you guys a second part of the
leak and that is that the iPhone 15 will
have a rounded back which is crazy we
have seen many leaks of having that
sandwich design with glass on the front
and the back an iPhone you know five
style or 5S style but here it looks like
we are going to get an iPhone 5c design
where we have the front completely being
flat the sides being mostly flat just
like our iPhone 12s through the 14s but
then the back has this curve that leads
into the back panel with shrimp Apple
Pro says will still have a glass back so
they're gonna have to make this thing
seamless now I don't know about you guys
but I actually really liked the iPhone
5Cs design even though it was
unapologetically plastic it felt great
in the hand now it kind of was a flaw
for a couple of reasons first off a lot
of people didn't want plastic sick but
mostly because Apple only had it be a
hundred dollars less than the 5S which
was way more powerful so even though the
design was great it felt great in the
hand it just didn't make sense to buy it
just like it doesn't make sense to buy
the 14 plus now why would Apple want to
do this well I think there are a few
different reasons first off with the
iPhone 12s through 14s you have a much
better grip it looks modern but it is
not as comfortable as the iPhone 10 10s
11 where you have those rounded edges
and it makes it feel Slimmer than it
actually is and with the iPhone 15 we
have a lot of info saying that they
could even be getting thicker with
bigger camera bumps and people don't
really like that we've also had rumors
that the camera bump but not might not
be that noticeable and one way is of
course to make it thicker because you
can't beat physics if you have such a
big camera system but when you make it
thicker it feels thicker but adding that
rounded Edge gives you the illusion that
it's not as thick and that helps solve
that problem so basically we're gonna
get the best of the iPhone 14 with the
nice grip and better comfort with the
older iPhones and it looks like a lot of
people are excited for this curved back
Edge as well and with that if the rumors
are true that we're gonna get an ultra
model that is more expensive while
people are gonna have an easier time
paying that extra cost if they're
getting titanium so that helps Apple we
also have the ultra Apple watch and so
that would give it a more cohesive
product line with the ultra iPhone as
well and we know that Apple has been
researching high-end titanium to use not
only for phones but also for MacBooks
now one of the issues with titanium is
that it smudges uh it is very hard to
code it so the ultra we just have one
color but Apple has been looking into an
apple won a patent for future devices
like a Macbook using Titanium with the
high gloss matte finish which helps with
resisting fingerprints now they actually
had a titanium power book before but
they had to paint it to help with
fingerprints and unfortunately the
painting solution sucked it would just
come off and look terrible but now along
with the patent about using Titanium on
different devices we also have another
one which is a special thin coating that
reduces fingerprints and this is really
cool and they might actually be already
using it on the Apple watch because I
don't notice any fingerprints whatsoever
on this Apple watch when I touch it
which is really great because this
iPhone with the stainless steel shows
fingerprints like crazy so with all of
that said I think this is gonna be a
killer device lighter weight more
durable more anti-fingerprint resin
assistant with these different Coatings
and this different surface treatments
that they have well that could allow
them to use different colors if they
want to along with adding colors to the
Apple watch which a lot of people ask
for and I think this is just going to be
a great iPhone you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comments once again
check out Rhino Shield and their crazy
Black Friday sale along with using our
coupon code to get even more money off
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign